[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen dies fällt
heute hier aus schmack halten ja ich bin
gerade in schmalkalden in thüringen
und hier war ich wirklich bisher noch
nie aber ich habe versprochen irgendwann
komme ich mal hierher
ich bin gerade hier bei fieber kennt ihr
wahrscheinlich schon aus meinen videos
das ist wirklich der weltbeste nougat
denn es gibt also ich habe bisher schon
viele sorten probiert und ich habe
fieber kennengelernt vor etwa vier
jahren auf der esm auf der süßwarenmesse
da kam der andreas mit der claudia
darüber auf dem stand und die habe ich
dann mitgenommen hat sally komm mit wir
zeigen wir den weltbesten nougat und so
war es auch
mittlerweile ist da echt eine tolle
freundschaft entstanden ich backe gerne
mit den produkten wir haben immer das
süßwarenregal bei uns voll viel weiß ein
echtes familienunternehmen mit tradition
die firma gibt es schon seit 1893 und
man kennt es auch so finde ich aus der
süßwarenbranche gar nicht mehr so häufig
denn oftmals werden produkte wirklich
die panisch zu werden gestreckt mit
zucker mit billigem palmfett und hier
ist gar nicht so bei fieber steht weckt
die qualität an höchster stelle wo ihr
kennt mich ich stelle mal für
nachhaltigkeit und nachhaltigkeit fängt
eben auch bei qualität an
und das schmeckt man in den produkten
wenn man das mal probiert hat schmeckt
man richtig die haselnuss raus die wird
vorher noch gerüstet das ganze haus hier
hinter mir liegt auch nach haselnuss und
hier machen wir jetzt heute eine richtig
tolle aktion denn es ist weltkindertag
und hierbei war gibt's einen richtig
tollen tag für kinder
hier ist es sogar ein feiertag bei uns
in baden württemberg leider nicht daher
kann samira leider nicht mit weil sie
schule hat aber wir werden jetzt hier
einen kinderball ihnen kurs machen
ich zeige euch kurz die nougat welt die
fiba welt und natürlich alles andere
rund um den nougat hinter mir seht ihr
schon die pralinen theke da gibt es ganz
viele handgemachte pralinen und die
konditorinnen oben die machen die alle
wirklich per hand 1000 stück in vier
stunden eine menge arbeit das sage ich
mal eine auswahl
hier gibt es natürlich immer je nach
saison verschiedene pralinen
es werde jetzt hier zwei davon ausgehen
und die werde ich dann später noch für
euch machen das heißt ihr seht dann wie
so eine praline von hand entsteht
darf ich vielleicht zum latte macchiato
probieren vielen dank
christa nougat noah darin loukas louka
troja luca pro jahr also helle nougat
stange dreischichtig oder muss ich
abreißen immer abreißt pflicht bei
pralinen und plätzchen nie auf einmal
rad schwingen immer ab weiß aber nicht
vor der kamera
der film darf ich vielleicht eine masse
von sally de beer irgendwie dunkler
schokolade
danke
mit kamera hat schon vorteile
ja
kann ich leider nicht mit euch teilen es
tut mir leid wird ja auch noch eine
und was sagt dir das nicht abgebissen
abgelegt sind gut
ich sag's doch mega lecker was ich zeig
euch jetzt wenn man die politik selber
macht wir gehen jetzt mal hoch zudem
konditorinnen in die confiserie kommt
man mit
jetzt bin ich hier gerade im oberen
stockwerk und hier ist alles gläsern das
heißt ihr könnt hier die gläserne
produktion anschauen ihr könnt ihr
selbst kurse buchen und zb pralinen
herstellen für firmenevents für einen
junggesellenabschied oder einfach so mit
der schulklasse oder auch wenn ihr sagt
kommt mit der familie machen einen
ausflug machen wir unsere eigenen
pralinen und guten rat erkennt man daran
dass er wirklich nur wenige zutaten hat
magath wird nämlich hergestellt aus
rasen aus etwas zucker kakao
erzeugnissen deshalb kakaobutter und
kakao und milchpulver das war mehr
braucht man dafür nicht und bei fieber
werden die haselnüsse gerüstet und man
kann hier vor ort auch wirklich die
haselnüsse mal umgerüstet probieren und
gerechnet hier und da gibt es echten
krassen unterschied
und hier kann man einfach reinschauen
zwischen ein bisschen informieren alles
anschauen probieren und natürlich auch
noch selber mitmachen
habt ihr eigentlich die riesen haselnuss
gesehen dagegen der hase lust und die
sieht man hier auch vom restaurant wenn
man im restaurant unten sitzt und guckt
sieht man die riesen haseloff ich vorher
nicht aufgefallen ich sage ich jetzt mal
richtig schöne pralinen und zwar nehmen
wir dafür dass royal luca also den
hellen nougat und den habe ich jetzt
bereits temperiert dh bei fritz halb
halt gemacht
also eben methode aber nicht zwei
drittel ein drittel sondern wirklich
halb halb so habe ich nur schöne kalte
konsistenz aber eben nicht zu kalt und
das läuft hier hinten auch nicht aus ich
habe es jetzt im spritzbeutel drin mit
einer ganz kleinen thüle habt ihr
schokoladen hohlkörper und jetzt wird es
hier eingeführt
am besten passt ihr den spritzbeutel
ganz vorne und erwärmt immer eine kleine
menge des lokals mit der hand denn mit
dem vollen spritzbeutel ist einfach viel
zu anstrengend und auf einem leeren
teller könnt ihr die spritztechnik auch
üben und dann erst die hohlkörper damit
gefüllt mit dem nougat royal zu arbeiten
ist gar nicht so einfach den deckel
kakaobutter drin und so ein großer
rassismus anteil dass es arbeiten
wirklich sehr temperatur abhängig ist
aber es ist halt auch in
qualitätsanspruch das heißt man hat hier
wirklich ganz schön haselnuss mit dabei
und das ist aber dafür umso besser
dann muss man echt zur bitte mit der
temperatur arbeiten und diese
handgemachten pralinen da gehört schon
einiges dazu schon nach hatte
handwerkskunst
man kann sich's leben schwer machen und
die pralinen selber machen oder man kann
den morath spielen
als mit etwas übung wird immer besser
aber da sind mir die konditoren hier
natürlich weit voraus und wenn jedoch
eine unschöne praline habt oder sie
einfach noch mal ein bisschen hübsch
dekorieren wollt könnt ihr noch die
gerösteten haselnüssen nehmen möchte ich
mir drauf legen die meisten finde ich
doch schon ganz schön dass ich so und
die haselnüsse die nachrichten und jetzt
gibt es noch eine weitere sorte februar
mit einem höheren tat bitter anteil und
damit rettet auch noch die hohlkörper
film
ich weiß gar nicht was meine
lieblingssorte wird ich kann mich nicht
entscheiden
[Musik]
ich habe hier schon mal schön geübt
haben einen kleinen vorsprung und ich
freue mich schon auf den kinderball im
kurs am weltkindertag dass wir mal
gespannt welche die rechte abtreten
werde
[Musik]
bei uns zu hause gibt es übrigens eine
praline und plätzchen ab weiß pflicht
also wenig praline oder plätzchen mache
dann muster morath mindestens einmal
abreißen
denn da ist so viel handwerk zu legen so
viel arbeit steckt drin und ich finde
wenn man sind dann einfach runter
schlingt das geht nicht man muss hier
einfach genießen so das war es meine
letzte parallele die ich gemacht habe
ich habe jetzt darf ich selber mal
probieren und immer anti rauch weisbrich
denken
[Musik]
jetzt einmal 10 uhr die kinder warten
schauen jetzt einem kinder verlieren
kurs zum weltkindertag kommt für holen
sein
hallo herzlich willkommen
die türken wieder zu herzlich willkommen
zum all ihren kurs das ist die dfl und
jetzt sagen wir uns berlin machen dann
kommt rein
für die eltern lassen was schön draußen
gesehen
helena und charlotte ihr seid ihr
perfekt ausgestattet können wir mal
einen schritt weiter
genau dann sehen wir uns gleich noch an
[Musik]
ja ich backe backe backe kuchen und du
und du ihr bekommt davon ein stück wenn
böse wütend traurig das mag ich lieber
haben mich darum ihm ein großes stück
von meinem leben voller glück
schön dass der welt
[Musik]
menschen die sind nicht glücklich sie
sind böse wütend und traurig man sieht
genau in ihrem gesicht
böse menschen schauen meistens als war
sie in ihrem leben noch nie froh
die menschen schauen meisten
letztens dringend hoffen das klo
wenn jemand traurig ist dann schaut er
und das macht mich überhaupt nicht vor
ja ich backe backe backe backe kuchen
viel glück
und du und du ihr bekommt davon ein
stück
denn bösewicht den trauring das mag ich
überhaupt nicht darum nimmt ein großes
stück vom kuchen voller glück
[Musik]
zwei esslöffel
freude
100 schwarz
[Musik]
von der fröhlichkeit
die ganz große krise
[Musik]
ja ich backe backe backe backe kuchen
wollen
kommt dass man ein stück
hüte trauring das mag ich überhaupt
nicht darum nimmt ein großes stück vom
kuchen verlag
[Musik]
[Applaus]
am ende des kurses bekam natürlich noch
jeder teilnehmer ein handsigniertes
nougat schokoladen die blume ich glaube
das sind die konditoren und die
konditorinnen der zukunft
[Musik]
also erstmal schön in thüringen zu sein
er und baut ihr zu sagen es ist muss
erstmal thüringen
er ist wirklich wunderschön hier
abgebissen
[Musik]
marianne team von trainer gebacken und
haben uns da unterschreiben
[Musik]
wir freuen uns nicht nur dass sie hier
sind natürlich auch der c liga ist auch
mein von morgen was du ja seit 20 18
hast und das ist diese die stiftung wir
finden dieses engagement soll neben
ihren fliegenden aktivitäten dass wir
uns entschieden haben im rahmen mit
dieser angst haltung gegenüber bild der
ist er die stiftung damit euch allen
einen scheck zu übergeben der dann für
die stützpunkte wenden und wieder
brauchen weiterhin und wir freuen uns
dass wir hier seit jenen tagen
am ende des weltkindertages hatten dann
alle kinder noch ziemlich viel spaß auf
dem spielplatz des fiber geländes
[Musik]
nur frauen um ich komm ich hab's
geschafft
[Gelächter]
ich war jetzt hier zwei richtig schöne
tage weiß wie war im schmack halten
die kinder haben auch alle ganz viel
spaß spielen hier alle noch fleißig ein
richtig toller wels kinder ragt der ist
übrigens erst seit diesem jahr ein
feiertag und beim privatteam bedanke ich
mich noch mal ganz ganz herzlich denn
wir haben eine spende bekommen für meine
stiftung meine stiftung gibt es schon
seit ende 2008 10
und wir sind dann natürlich auch auf
spenden angewiesen unsere partner
unterstützen uns immer auch die dass
firmen haben uns bereits unterstützt und
so können wir schon in diesem jahr ganz
viele tolle projekte machen wie zum
beispiel eine küche für den kindergarten
und auch so werden wir noch
deutschlandweit ganz viele andere
projekte machen
und ja ich glaube hier war es ein
richtig schöner weltkindertag wir werden
wieder nach hause gehen
der bub hat schon einige kilo lukas
verdrückt ein bisschen aufnehmen und
somit wird und vorrat zu hause und ich
hoffe euch das video gefallen und vielen
dank an alle die hier dabei waren in
schwarz weiß
[Musik]
ich finde ganz tag hier sein
es ist kostenlos überhaupt sollte aber
vielleicht nicht machen und zwar ist
mein lieblingsort ohne spaß probiert mal
erdbeerjoghurt fruchttiger genuss
richtig cool und es gibt ein unterschied
zwischen konsumieren und genießen
murat konsumiert immer ich versuche zu
ich person zu genießen da man konsumiere
ist einfach ganz langsam im mund
zergehen lassen ja richtig ja bitte und
gerade diese socken erdbeerjoghurt post
genuss ist wirklich ein absolut in ist
das 1 0 nicht kauen langsam schmelzen
lassen